uh how are you guys doing today
very good man how are you doing good um
you guys came by our studio i believe at
sundance
uh for this but i hadn't seen the movie
um and now i've seen it and i want to
talk to you both because
you both did such an incredible job
thank you
thank you does that mean back then you
didn't want it to talk to us
no i mean you listen you have a right
you have a reputation you're like
diva-esque i need to avoid people i'm
joking that it's so not
really difficult i'm so i'm so joking
listen the thing about this movie
is um first of all i really want to say
this is a great film and i really hope
anyone watching this
will tune in i i really want to know
because it's
what was it like reading the script for
the first time because there's so much
that keeps you guessing and a lot of
in-camera edits and a lot of
you wondering what exactly is going on
i'm curious what is it like to read that
on the page
when i read the script i had no idea
what would what was actually going on it
was the same experience that i imagine
you have when you watch the film
um and that was what was compelling
about it i couldn't stop reading it
because i wanted to know what happened
and when i found out what happened i was
shocked
and i started sobbing it was very
visceral
and very intuitive and it was a it was a
really beautiful script to read
it felt like something that was very
literary
when i decided to do the film and we it
came to making the film
it was a totally different experience it
was suddenly incredibly technical
and how do you make that work it was
like it was a very difficult thing to
pivot between the present and the past
you know it was diego and i there was it
was very clunky there was no
like of those scenes where we kind of
hop back and forth and comment on
ourselves
um difficult to feel good about that
please be aware
there's smoke in the kitchen
it's the english smoke alarm please be
aware your house
is on fire
i do know
[Music]
to be honest when i when i when i read
the script
i wasn't thinking as an actor
or about playing it you know or
or anything but just like how
eloquent it was you know how well
written it was
how uh smart and brave it was uh
that there was this this it sounded like
a
an amazing challenge not many films are
actually taking you know it was a very
risky project it sounded risky because
it made sense but at the same time you
could see
easily how this was gonna become
unachievable
too you know because it aims really far
and uh and emotionally i was there with
the characters because i think it's uh
it's just simple people regular people
going through the most intense moment
you can go in your life
which is parenthood you know and uh
and i thought this is this is a really
smart way to do a film about love
about everyone you know uh
and uh it it keep me in the right spot
because
i found myself reflecting on it for
weeks
um yeah i i uh it really punched me in
the face
last night as i watched the film and it
it really it really hit me especially i
think we've all
dealt with loss and this film is very
powerful um
i have to ask you sienna because you
really give
a a really emotional performance in this
film and you touch on the fact that
there's
very complicated camera moves and and
sequences where you have to hit certain
marks
what is it like as an actor trying to
maintain that emotional honesty
in a scene while also knowing you need
to do certain moves
and adjust you know and be in certain
positions for the camera
it's something that i'm not so good i'm
i'm really i feel like
where my capabilities lie is sort of
being truthful
and like diving into something um
that side of it was complicated it just
took a real
uh a real trust in tara and a real
patience and a real kind of
i don't know it's it's difficult you you
don't have a choice when you're doing an
independent film and you have a limited
budget and you have limited time and you
have to get something within a certain
bandwidth
um it's frustrating it's complicated but
it's just like it's it
and you hope that it pays off you never
know when it's something
like this it's sort of untried untested
unlike anything i'd ever done before um
but i understood the vision that she had
and i saw the film and i was like god
she knew what she was doing she
achieved what she set out to do and i'm
so glad that we kind of trusted her
through it
uh for both of you i've spoken to a lot
of actors that talk about how
they always wish they could refilm the
first two days of any movie
because they feel like you know like
they now know the characters after a few
days
do you guys have that do you have that
experience on on projects
yeah every project
i mean every project in fact you you
know it's
it has like become a rule on a way you
know
uh that at least when i work in projects
more as a producer
or even as a director you you have to
know that
the first two days you're gonna have to
go back to them if you don't budget that
at the beginning
you're doing a big mistake because it's
and who can be so sure at the beginning
of anything
i mean you trust someone doing one thing
for the first time that they know what
they're doing
i mean you're you have you're doing
something
really wrong you know and and in film
it's all about what happens
with the encounter of people so you have
to be patient
i just heard something uh someone told
me uh
that donald sutherland in all of his
contracts he makes it that the first
week of filming has to be from the
middle of the movie
because of how it he thinks that in the
middle people have already bought into
what he's selling at the beginning
so and that's in his contract i thought
it was brilliant
he was so good in the undoing my god
he was amazing i'm gonna i'm gonna take
a leaf out of that book
listen i i think it's actually after
hearing that i'm like that's the most
brilliant advice i've ever heard
smart yeah it's almost like he knows
what he's doing yeah
thank you yeah by this point he probably
does
yeah he's he's okay um before i run out
of time i i uh
diego i have to ask you an individual
question because i'm a huge star wars
fan
and i know that you're filming something
right now um
what i i know you can't talk
specifically about anything but i'm
curious
what was it what is it like what was it
like reading the scripts
for this project for the first time and
because i'm just curious what you can
tease about it and your reaction to the
scripts
i was yeah i'm still in love with them
you know i'm still in love with all the
material i
i i i really appreciate collaborating
with tony gilroy
he's amazing and uh
very exciting very exciting i can tell
you that
he's it's it's quite a unique approach
to the world of star wars
uh and uh i'm loving every second yeah
i wish i could ask you 17 other
questions about it uh
i'm just saying i'm very excited i'm not
gonna answer them but you can i mean
100 and also i'm looking forward to an
anatomy of a scandal
thank you good yay yeah on that note i
already got to go but seriously anyone
watching this interview
uh uh watch this film it you guys did
such a great job